Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. The topic for this episode is psychologically healthy workplaces. We spend a significant portion of our lives at work and feeling miserable on the job can be detrimental to our mental and physical health and productivity. A work environment that is psychologically healthy is one that focuses on employees' health and well-being and the bottom line. To explain more about what makes a workplace psychologically healthy, our guests for this episode are Dr. David Ballard, who leads APA's Office of Applied Psychology,
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目的主题是心理健康的工作场所。我们生命中很大一部分时间是在工作中度过的，在工作中感到痛苦会对我们的身心健康和生产力造成损害。一个心理健康的工作环境，是指既关注员工的身心健康，又关注组织经济效益的环境。为了更深入地解释什么是心理健康的工作场所，我们本期的嘉宾是美国心理学会应用心理学办公室负责人大卫·巴拉德博士，
and Bryce Vion, president and CEO of Autosoft, one of the winners of our 2019 Psychologically Healthy Workplace Awards. Autosoft, based in Northwest Pennsylvania, is an auto dealer management system provider. Welcome, David Ballard and Mr. Vionn. Thanks, thanks, Caitlin. Thanks. Great to be here. First off, Dr. Ballard, can you explain what it means to be a psychologically healthy workplace? Sure. Being a psychologically healthy workplace really just means paying attention to employee well-being and organizational performance and working toward the best outcomes possible for all of the people involved. So that means employees, the organization, shareholders or owners of the organization, and even the community that an organization is embedded in. And there's not one single way of doing this.
以及Autosoft公司总裁兼首席执行官布莱斯·维恩，该公司是我们2019年“心理健康工作场所奖”的获奖者之一。Autosoft总部位于宾夕法尼亚州西北部，是一家汽车经销商管理系统提供商。欢迎大卫·巴拉德博士和维恩先生。谢谢，谢谢你，凯特琳。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。首先，巴拉德博士，您能解释一下什么是心理健康的工作场所吗？当然。心理健康的工作场所实际上意味着关注员工的福祉和组织绩效，并努力为所有相关人员实现最佳结果。这意味着员工、组织、股东或组织所有者，甚至是组织所处的社区。而且，实现这一目标并没有单一的方法。
There's not a one-size-fits-all approach. It really is about taking comprehensive steps to create this kind of healthy and productive environment. And the types of things we see in organizations fall into some general categories, employee involvement, growth and development opportunities, health and safety initiatives, work-life balance and flexibility, employee recognition, and then good, effective two-way communication in an organization. And in an environment like that, where a psychologically healthy workplace is created, it helps employees and the organization thrive. Yeah, how so? Well, it creates a supportive environment so that those benefits and perks that come into play help employees be at their best when they're on the job so that they can manage the competing demands in their lives. They feel recognized and rewarded for their contributions to the organization and really be engaged in the work that they're contributing to the organization. and really be engaged in the work that they're contributing to the organization to move it forward and advance its mission.
没有一种放之四海而皆准的方法。这实际上是采取全面的措施来创造这种健康和高效的环境。我们在组织中看到的这类事物通常分为几个大类：员工参与、成长与发展机会、健康与安全倡议、工作与生活的平衡与灵活性、员工认可，以及组织内部良好、有效的双向沟通。在这样一个创造了心理健康工作场所的环境中，它有助于员工和组织共同繁荣。是的，怎么说呢？嗯，它创造了一个支持性的环境，使得这些福利和津贴能够发挥作用，帮助员工在工作中发挥出最佳水平，从而让他们能够应对生活中相互竞争的需求。他们感到自己的贡献得到了认可和回报，并真正投入到他们为组织所做的工作中，
And do you think by and large organizations understand what it means to be psychologically healthy? I think increasingly they do, but there's a lot of variability. Some organizations are really far ahead, and they've been doing this for years, and others are just starting to get on board. Overall, we've seen employers move from a really narrow focus on physical health to more of a wellness approach. and now increasingly focus on well-being, so really looking at the whole person in the work environment. So they're not just focusing on health risk reduction and cost savings anymore. They're really looking at the full value that these efforts can contribute to the organization and to the employees who work there. A lot of organizations know it's the right thing to do.
并真正投入到他们为组织所做的工作中，以推动其发展并实现其使命。您认为大体上组织是否了解什么是心理健康？我认为他们越来越了解了，但存在很大的差异。有些组织确实遥遥领先，他们多年来一直这样做，而另一些组织才刚刚开始加入。总的来说，我们看到雇主已经从仅仅关注身体健康转向了更全面的健康方法，现在越来越关注福祉，也就是真正关注工作环境中的“全人”。所以他们不再仅仅关注降低健康风险和节省成本。他们真正着眼于这些努力能为组织和在那里工作的员工带来的全部价值。许多组织知道这是正确的事情。
They want to take care of employees and create a good environment. But employers also get that this is smart business. This are good business decisions. And therefore, the more they understand the importance of it, we have to do a better job of getting out information about how you actually accomplish this. So more employers understand it, but they don't necessarily know how to do it. And this also helps employees with employee retention. This helps productivity. You know, I think that's one of those things that maybe an employer, do you think they think, okay, if I'm letting people use time to exercise, are they being productive?
他们想照顾员工并创造一个良好的环境。但雇主也明白这是明智的商业行为。这些都是好的商业决策。因此，他们越了解其重要性，我们就越需要做好信息传播工作，告诉大家如何真正实现这一点。所以更多的雇主了解它，但他们不一定知道怎么做。这也帮助雇主留住员工。这有助于提高生产力。你知道，我认为这可能是雇主会想的事情之一，他们会想，好吧，如果我让员工利用时间锻炼，他们会有生产力吗？
But research shows that it does help. It does boost productivity. and when people feel connected, right, to people feel like they're supported, they feel more connected to their work. Yeah, even in that example that you gave, there's research that shows that even when employees take time out of their workday to exercise, they more than make up for that time and the gain productivity throughout the day when they do that. So, overall, these kinds of efforts benefit employees. They benefit the organization. You know, on the employee front, it contributes to higher levels of job satisfaction, better physical and mental health, the morality. is better in a workplace, they're more motivated, and they're better able to manage the stress
但研究表明，这确实有帮助。它确实能提高生产力。当人们感到有联系时，对吧，当人们感到被支持时，他们会感到与工作联系更紧密。是的，即使在你给出的那个例子中，也有研究表明，即使员工在工作日抽出时间锻炼，当他们这样做时，他们不仅能补回那些时间，还能在一天中获得更高的生产力。所以，总的来说，这类努力对员工有益。它们对组织也有益。你知道，在员工方面，它有助于提高工作满意度、改善身心健康，士气在工作场所也会更好，他们更有动力，也更有能力管理压力，
that they face day to day on the job. But on the employer side, there are a lot of benefits as well. So, yes, it can help reduce problematic things like absenteeism and turnover, presenteism where people are physically on the job, but they're not performing up to their full potential because they're burned out or sick. But more importantly, it improves performance and productivity. It can improve product and service quality, customer service and satisfaction ratings, reduce accidents and injuries. It can help an employer become an employer of choice. And that's really critical because if you can attract and retain the best quality workers, that gives you a competitive advantage in the marketplace. And you do interviews in the media all the time about
他们每天在工作中面临的压力。但在雇主方面，也有很多好处。所以，是的，它可以帮助减少缺勤和人员流动等问题，减少“出勤主义”，即人们虽然在工作，但因为精疲力竭或生病而没有发挥出全部潜力。但更重要的是，它提高了绩效和生产力。它可以提高产品和服务质量、客户服务和满意度评分，减少事故和伤害。它可以帮助雇主成为首选雇主。这非常关键，因为如果你能吸引并留住最优秀的员工，这就会在市场上给你带来竞争优势。你经常在媒体上接受关于
this very topic. And you've said that company culture matters the most. So how do those perks in the incentives fit in with the larger culture? Yeah, that's a very important point because it's not just about the perks or the benefits or the policies or programs that an employer puts in place, those values have to get instilled in the actual culture of the organization. I mean, employees are smart. They know when an organization doesn't mean it, and they're putting something in place to squeeze more productivity out of them. And they know when employees don't really, employers don't really care about their well-being. So it has to get embedded in the culture. And the organization has to walk the talk. You can't just say that you care about it
这个话题的采访。你说过公司文化最重要。那么这些津贴和激励措施是如何融入更大的文化中的呢？是的，这是一个非常重要的观点，因为这不仅仅是关于雇主提供的津贴、福利、政策或计划，这些价值观必须灌输到组织的实际文化中。我的意思是，员工很聪明。他们知道组织什么时候不是真心的，他们只是为了榨取更多的生产力而实施某些措施。他们知道雇主什么时候并不真正关心他们的福祉。所以它必须植根于文化中。组织必须言行一致。你不能仅仅说你关心它，
and slap some programs in place, the psychosocial work environment is really critical. And this is why psychology is important in the workplace, because those organizational level factors, the way work is designed and carried out in organizations, makes a huge difference. Having supportive supervisors, the level of trust that exists in an organization, whether employees feel valued for their contributions, whether they're positive interpersonal relationships and civility in the interactions that occur. there and whether employees are engaged in meaningful work where they feel connected to the mission of the organization and they understand their role in helping to advance that.
然后草草实施一些计划，心理社会工作环境确实至关重要。这就是为什么心理学在工作场所很重要，因为那些组织层面的因素，即工作中设计和执行的方式，会产生巨大的影响。拥有支持性的主管、组织中存在的信任水平、员工是否感到自己的贡献受到重视、人际关系是否积极、互动中是否有礼貌，以及员工是否从事有意义的工作，在那里他们感到与组织的使命相连，并了解他们在帮助推进该使命中的作用。
Why do you think there's been this shift? I mean, do you think these, all these wellness programs are, you know, perks and things like that? Why do you think it's so important today? Do we see this in the workplace 30, 40 years ago? Well, a lot of these efforts have existed for a long time, but they had a much narrower focus. So I think it's coming from multiple angles. I think employers are increasingly coming to understand that creating a psychologically healthy workplace is good for employees and is good for business, too. I think there's a shift in expectation among workers who are entering the workforce that they expect to have more flexibility and to juggle the competing things they have in life.
你认为为什么会出现这种转变？我的意思是，你认为这些所有的健康计划，你知道，津贴之类的东西？你为什么认为今天它如此重要？我们在30、40年前的工作场所看到过这种情况吗？嗯，这些努力中有很多已经存在很长时间了，但它们的关注点要狭窄得多。所以我认为这是从多个角度出发的。我认为雇主们越来越认识到，创造一个心理健康的工作场所对员工有益，对企业也有益。我认为进入职场的员工的期望发生了转变，他们期望有更多的灵活性，并能兼顾生活中相互竞争的事情。
They expect to have a job where they feel like they're contributing to something bigger than themselves. And then even in public opinion, a lot more of this is talked about openly. So if an employer is not taking these steps, ways will go elsewhere. They'll go seek out jobs somewhere else that they see as a better work environment. Yeah. What does EPA look for in award winners for the psychologically healthy workplace awards? Well, the process for our award evaluation is actually quite rigorous. So it's not just a vanity workplace award where you talk about how great you are in a short essay. And if
他们期望拥有一份让他们觉得自己在为比自己更伟大的事业做出贡献的工作。甚至在公众舆论中，更多地公开讨论这些问题。所以如果雇主不采取这些措施，员工就会去别处。他们会去寻找他们认为工作环境更好的地方。是的。美国心理学会（APA）在评选“心理健康工作场所奖”时看重什么？嗯，我们的奖项评估过程实际上非常严格。所以这不仅仅是一个虚荣的工作场所奖，你写一篇短文谈谈自己有多棒，如果
it sounds nice, we give you an award. You know, as psychologists, we're held to a different standard. So we really want to bring our research to bear and our assessment skills in psychology to evaluate these applicant organizations. So there's a multi-step process that involves collecting qualitative and quantitative information from the organizations. We conduct online employee surveys of the applicants. We hear from employees themselves. And one of the unique things about the program is we actually go out and do site visits. So we tour the facility. We meet with the organization's leaders and do focus groups with employees and look for a convergence of data and from all of those sources to identify organizations that are doing this well.
听起来不错，我们就给你颁奖。你知道，作为心理学家，我们受到不同的标准约束。所以我们真的想运用我们的研究成果和心理学评估技能来评估这些申请组织。因此，这是一个涉及从组织收集定性和定量信息的多步骤过程。我们对申请者进行在线员工调查。我们听取员工自己的意见。该项目独特之处之一是，我们实际上会进行实地考察。所以我们参观设施。我们与组织领导人会面，并与员工进行焦点小组讨论，并寻找所有这些来源的数据汇合，以确定哪些组织做得很好。
So we look for organizations that understand the importance of creating a psychologically healthy workplace and how that connects to employee well-being and the success and performance of the organization. And we look for organizations that are taking steps in all of those major areas I mentioned earlier, employee involvement and growth and development and so on. And we also look for positive outcomes on the employee front and for the organization. We want to see that this is actually accomplishing something in the organizations. And then finally, we look for an ongoing commitment from organizations that creating a psychologically healthy workplace isn't an in-state.
所以我们寻找那些了解创造心理健康工作场所的重要性，以及它如何与员工福祉和组织成功与绩效相联系的组织。我们寻找那些在我之前提到的所有主要领域（员工参与、成长与发展等）采取措施的组织。我们还寻找员工方面和组织方面的积极成果。我们想看到这在组织中确实取得了一些成就。最后，我们寻找组织持续的承诺，即创造一个心理健康的工作场所不是一个终点。
It's an ongoing process that even companies that are doing great can always work to improve things and the environment changes. So it's something you have to stay on top of and continue to make strides to make it even better moving forward. Okay. Let's turn over to Autosoft for a few. Mr. Vian, congratulations. Your company's had a good turnaround story that happened in the past. few years. Can you talk about what happened? Sure. Yeah. When I came to AutofSoft full-time, because it's a family business, but I stepped out for a while. And when I came back, I, you know,
这是一个持续的过程，即使是做得很好的公司也总能努力改进，环境也在变化。所以这是你必须保持领先并继续努力，在未来使其变得更好的事情。好的。让我们转到Autosoft公司谈谈。维恩先生，恭喜。你们公司在过去几年里有一个很好的扭亏为盈的故事。你能谈谈发生了什么吗？当然。是的。当我全职来到Autosoft时，因为这是家族企业，但我离开了一段时间。当我回来时，我，你知道，
I had a vision that I wanted to take the company in a new direction because we were building new products and needed to move up market in our industry. And when I came back, I saw a culture that was missing. There wasn't a management style that really fit with how I wanted to run things. and I always had a value in, you know, the mixture of, you know, feeling like there's a purpose in the work and big goals, but also just having some trust and some, you know, really excitement about the work that we do. And when I came back, we didn't have that here. We had a lot of people who, you know, didn't understand whether they were doing a good job or not. We didn't have, you know, reviews or one-on-ones. So it actually, when I first came back, it took a lot of time to build some trust because when I started to put in these new programs, even though these were positive programs, the first reaction was just skepticism and maybe it was something new and it was change.
我有一个愿景，我想带领公司走向一个新的方向，因为我们正在开发新产品，需要在行业中向高端市场迈进。当我回来时，我看到了一种缺失的文化。没有一种管理风格真正符合我想要经营公司的方式。我一直重视，你知道，那种感觉工作有目标、有宏大目标，但同时也拥有一些信任，以及对我们所做工作真正感到兴奋的混合体。当我回来时，我们这里没有这些。我们有很多员工，你知道，他们不知道自己是否做得好。我们没有，你知道，绩效评估或一对一谈话。所以实际上，当我刚回来时，花了很多时间来建立一些信任，因为当我开始实施这些新计划时，尽管这些是积极的计划，但最初的反应只是怀疑，也许是因为这是新事物，是变革。
So that's where some of this started off and it took us years to get to where we are today. Yeah. How did you get past that, those trust challenges you just mentioned? Really just open communications, laying out a plan that they never really understood before, didn't have a lot of visibility or ownership to before. You know, a lot of the employees, you know, didn't feel like they had the autonomy or the power to make decisions or help make, you know, plans or put new projects in place or accomplish new things that would help the company. So it really opened up a lot of trust and two-way communication. across the company. And can you now talk about what your company's culture is like today and what benefits
所以这就是这一切开始的地方，我们花了几年时间才达到今天的水平。是的。你是如何克服你刚才提到的那些信任挑战的？真的只是开放的沟通，制定一个他们以前从未真正理解、没有太多可见度或所有权的计划。你知道，很多员工，你知道，觉得他们没有自主权或权力来做决定，或者帮助制定，你知道，计划，或者实施新项目，或者完成有助于公司的新事情。所以这确实在整个公司打开了大量的信任和双向沟通。你能谈谈你们公司今天的文化是什么样的，以及你们提供什么福利吗？
you provide employees? I know that wellness programs are popular with Autosoft. Yeah, no, we probably have too many programs in some ways. We would do a lot. And, you know, I think it's just, you know, as we saw some of the success out of these programs as we put them in place, I think we're always trying to, you know, look ahead. You know, it's an ever-evolving thing. and the business is always changing and the needs of the people are always changing and the demographics are changing all the time.
我知道健康计划在Autosoft很受欢迎。是的，不，我们在某些方面可能计划太多了。我们做了很多。而且，你知道，我认为这只是，你知道，当我们看到这些计划实施后取得的一些成功时，我认为我们总是试图，你知道，向前看。你知道，这是一个不断发展的事情。而且业务总是在变化，人们的需求总是在变化，人口结构也在不断变化。
So we're always trying to make sure we have the right fit to the right people, the culture, and the business needs and the, you know, in what we need out of the business as far as performance goes. And so it's a balance all the time, but we do all kinds of programs, both physical and mental and just even just some of the way we interact here, you know, has a lot to do with, you know, have a lot. a healthy environment. Yeah, I want to talk about a couple of specific things you have going on. What's your You've Been Caught initiative? The You've Been Caught is it's kind of a peer-based program where, you know, it really rewards people for, you know, giving some recognition to people for making the right choices in their life, whether it be healthy choices, you know, maybe they, you know,
所以我们总是试图确保我们对合适的人、文化、业务需求以及我们在绩效方面对业务的需求有正确的匹配。所以这始终是一个平衡，但我们做各种各样的计划，无论是身体上的还是心理上的，甚至只是我们在这里互动的方式，你知道，都与，你知道，拥有一个健康的环境有很大关系。是的，我想谈谈你们正在进行的几件事。你们的“你被抓住了”（You've Been Caught）倡议是什么？“你被抓住了”是一个基于同伴的计划，你知道，它真正奖励人们，你知道，给予那些在生活中做出正确选择的人一些认可，无论是健康的饮食选择，你知道，也许他们，你知道，
brought a healthy lunch or, you know, we're doing well on sticking to, you know, their diet or encouraging others to adopt healthy ways, things like that. So it's almost, you know, you could walk by and you could see somebody taking a piece of candy or something and say, ah, you've been caught, you know, and it's just kind of, you know, it's like drop and do 10 pushups. And, you know, there's a little bit of a, you know, a little bit of a family feel of like, you know, hey, we're going to help each other do better. And how is that caught on with your pun intended? It's caught on.
带了健康的午餐，或者，你知道，在坚持，你知道，他们的饮食方面做得很好，或者鼓励他人采取健康的方式，诸如此类。所以它几乎是，你知道，你可以走过去，看到有人在吃糖果之类的东西，然后说，啊，你被抓住了，你知道，这只是一种，你知道，就像“做10个俯卧撑”。而且，你知道，有一种，你知道，一点点家庭的感觉，就像，你知道，嘿，我们要互相帮助做得更好。这在你们公司流行起来了吗？流行起来了。
Yeah, no, it's caught on really well. We've actually sort of evolved that program now. We've included, we call it the token award program. So it now involves a little wider peer-based program that includes some monetary and gift rewards for achieving goals, personal goals and things like that. And you also have something called a Take 10 station, which I found, found interesting, where employees can take a break from their work to de-stress and they can do fun things like put together a puzzle, a color, or make a paper airplane.
是的，不，它非常流行。我们实际上已经演变了那个计划。我们包含了，我们称之为代币奖励计划。所以它现在涉及一个更广泛的基于同伴的计划，包括一些货币和礼品奖励，用于实现目标、个人目标等等。你们还有一个叫“休息10分钟”（Take 10）的站点，我觉得很有趣，员工可以在那里从工作中休息一下以缓解压力，他们可以做一些有趣的事情，比如拼图、涂色或折纸飞机。
You talk about how that's helped your employees during the day? Yeah, like we have these stations throughout the buildings and on the different floors. And, you know, really, I'll see employees that maybe they're waiting for a meeting to get into a meeting and they're kind of gathered around one of the tables and they're kind of chit-chatting and talking to each other, get to know each other. But also at the same time, you know, they're doing a puzzle together.
你能谈谈这在白天是如何帮助你们员工的吗？是的，我们在建筑物和不同的楼层都有这些站点。而且，你知道，我真的会看到员工，也许他们正在等待开会，他们聚集在其中一张桌子旁，他们正在闲聊，互相交谈，互相了解。但与此同时，你知道，他们正在一起拼图。
They're just doing a project together that's kind of relaxing. And sometimes I think it eases their mind a little bit before they go into a meeting that might be a little stressful or a little tense and helps get them, you know, to relax and get to know each other a little bit. And how does that help with employees just getting to know each other a little bit in a more of a casual way, and not just in a meeting environment or in the hall,
他们只是在做一个有点放松的共同项目。有时我认为这在他们进入可能有点压力或紧张的会议之前，稍微放松了他们的心情，并帮助他们，你知道，放松下来并互相了解一点。这如何帮助员工以更随意的方式互相了解，而不仅仅是在会议环境或大厅里，
always like doing something kind of fun together and definitely totally unrelated to your to their work. Yeah, there's just a yeah. I mean that camaraderie is is important. I think there's also the trust factor, you know, just understanding each other and just understanding that we're all working towards the same things as a team. And, you know, that comes from interactions that are both in the business and doing the right things in the business together and treating each other fairly and helping each other. But also outside, we have a lot of, programs or, you know, a lot of events that we do outside, even like, you know, happy hours and bowling and different things that we get people together. And they, they are a diverse group,
总是像一起做一些有趣的事情，而且绝对与他们的工作完全无关。是的，有一种，是的。我的意思是那种情谊很重要。我认为还有信任因素，你知道，只是互相了解，只是明白我们作为一个团队都在为同样的事情努力。而且，你知道，这来自于在业务中互动，在业务中做正确的事情，公平对待彼此并互相帮助。但在外部，我们也有很多，计划，或者，你知道，我们做的很多外部活动，甚至像，你知道，欢乐时光、保龄球和各种我们把人们聚在一起的事情。他们，他们是一个多元化的群体，
so we don't always get to work together directly. So when we get outside the office, it gives us a chance to get to know each other and a little bit about our families or what we like, what we don't like, and helps us work better together so we can focus on some strengths and weaknesses. And when you were going through the change when you took over, did you find that the importance of being transparent and sharing what was going on with your employees was helpful because I often know that information helps ease anxiety when people, you know, when you have a restructuring and you have change, what was helpful for you? I think it was helpful to lay out the plan and the course and how we were going to get to the
所以我们并不总是能直接一起工作。所以当我们走出办公室时，这给了我们一个机会去了解彼此，了解一点关于我们的家庭，或者我们喜欢什么，不喜欢什么，这有助于我们更好地合作，这样我们就可以专注于一些优势和劣势。当你接手时经历变革时，你是否发现透明并与员工分享正在发生的事情很有帮助，因为我经常知道，当你有重组和变革时，信息有助于缓解焦虑，什么对你有帮助？我认为制定计划和路线，以及我们将如何到达我们前往的
destination we were headed for. And I think as a privately owned company, smaller, you know, small to midsize company, you know, we actually share probably. more than some of the public companies do with their employees as far as, you know, financial information, financial goals, product goals, departmental and personal goals. You know, we go through a lot of, you know, goal setting exercises. And out of that, you know, comes a lot of the transparency of what we're all trying to get done. And it starts to make sure we're all working to towards the same things and just builds out a lot of transparency in the trust in the in the company. And when you mentioned, you know, the previous days to now, you said that there were no
目的地，这很有帮助。而且我认为作为一家私营公司，规模较小，你知道，中小型公司，你知道，我们实际上分享的可能比一些上市公司与员工分享的更多，就，你知道，财务信息、财务目标、产品目标、部门和个人目标而言。你知道，我们经历了很多，你知道，目标设定练习。从中，你知道，产生了我们都在努力完成的事情的透明度。这开始确保我们都在为同样的事情努力，并只是在公司内部建立了大量的透明度和信任。当你提到，你知道，以前的日子到现在，你说没有
annual reviews. And now you even go above and beyond that and you have monthly reviews. So how has that helped your employees and what changes have you seen? Yeah, it's part of that same very open, transparent, you know, communication and very direct. I mean, I'm personally very direct with people, so I'm not afraid to hold back or tell them what I really think or tell them the truth. And I think some of that from the top down, you know, starts to become part of the culture or the expectation that, hey, if you feel a certain way or you don't agree with something or you do, like being, you know, being transparent and open is a good thing to have. It helps us, you know, get things done faster and make decisions faster. and I think that, you know, having the one-on-ones, at one point we actually had one-on-ones weekly, and some departments would do, you know, just a quick 20-minute one-on-one with each of their employees
年度评估。而现在你甚至超越了这一点，有了月度评估。那么这如何帮助了你的员工，你看到了什么变化？是的，这是那种非常开放、透明、你知道，沟通的一部分，而且非常直接。我的意思是，我个人对人非常直接，所以我不会害怕退缩或告诉他们我的真实想法或告诉他们真相。而且我认为其中一些自上而下的，你知道，开始成为文化或期望的一部分，即，嘿，如果你有某种感觉，或者你不同意某事，或者你同意，像，你知道，透明和开放是一件好事。它帮助我们，你知道，更快地完成事情并更快地做出决定。而且我认为，你知道，进行一对一谈话，在某一点上我们实际上每周进行一次一对一谈话，有些部门会做，你知道，只是与他们的每个员工进行快速的20分钟一对一谈话，
and just to get a feel for how they're doing and how they're feeling. And, you know, is this a time to maybe shift some of your work so that you can, like, clear your mind a little bit or maybe get a little refresh? You know, sometimes, you know, change is good. and then others would do, you know, biweekly or monthly. We're actually evolving that this year. Like I say, I think it's important to constantly evolve things. And I think we're moving to more of a, you know, still a biweekly to monthly one-on-ones.
只是为了了解他们做得如何，感觉如何。而且，你知道，这是不是一个可能调整你工作的时间，这样你就可以，比如，稍微清空一下你的思绪，或者也许稍微刷新一下？你知道，有时，你知道，改变是好的。然后其他人会做，你知道，每两周或每月一次。我们今年实际上正在演变它。就像我说的，我认为不断演变事情很重要。而且我认为我们正在转向更多，你知道，仍然是每两周到每月一次的一对一谈话。
So you get the real-time feedback and very direct. Yeah. But we also are moving to maybe once or twice a year, more thorough review so that we really understand, you know, what we need to work on and where we're doing well. Right. Do your employees feel empowered to manage up, meaning they feel comfortable providing feedback to their managers or to company leadership? Not in all cases, to be honest.
所以你得到实时反馈，而且非常直接。是的。但我们也正在转向也许一年一次或两次，更彻底的评估，这样我们真正了解，你知道，我们需要在什么方面努力，以及我们在哪里做得很好。对。你的员工是否感到有权向上管理，意思是他们感到舒服地向他们的经理或公司领导提供反馈？说实话，并非所有情况都是这样。
I think that we have some room to improve there. I think that we need to do better at some of our 360 reviews and some of the openness, you know, in both directions. I think that it just depends on the department or the group of people, the individuals, and the relationship with their managers. Right. And that's something, as you, David mentioned, or Dr. Baller mentioned in the beginning,
我认为我们在那方面还有改进的空间。我认为我们需要在一些360度评估和一些开放性方面做得更好，你知道，在两个方向上。我认为这只是取决于部门或群体、个人以及他们与经理的关系。对。这就是，正如你，大卫提到的，或者巴拉德博士在开始时提到的，
is the importance of always evolving. So that's something Autosoft is doing in that regard. Yeah, all the time. Yeah. And so you're a smaller company, and obviously we hear often about all the amazing perks a company like Google or Facebook can provide employees. So, but with a smaller company like yours,
是不断演变的重要性。所以这是Autosoft在这方面正在做的事情。是的，一直都在做。是的。所以你是一家较小的公司，显然我们经常听到像谷歌或Facebook这样的公司能为员工提供的所有惊人的福利。所以，但是对于像你们这样的小公司，
what advice do you have for other CEOs in that realm? Because obviously we can always look to these, big behemoth examples is like the pinnacle of employee wellness and incentive programs, but obviously we all can't provide those same things for a smaller company like yours. So what advice do you have? I would say start off small. That's how we started. And a lot of it's really about the employee experience. And you'd be amazed at, you know, things like the open feedback and the little things like company T-shirts or branded T-shirts or little prizes for doing a good job and a little bit of recognition goes a long way. I'd say just some of the small things to
你对那个领域的其他首席执行官有什么建议？因为显然我们总是可以看向这些，庞然大物般的例子，就像员工健康和激励计划的巅峰，但显然我们不能都为像你们这样的小公司提供同样的东西。所以你有什么建议？我会说从小处着手。我们就是这样开始的。而且很多实际上是关于员工体验的。你会惊讶于，你知道，像开放反馈和像公司T恤或品牌T恤或做了一份好工作的小奖品这样的小事，一点点认可就会大有帮助。我会说只是做一些小事来
start out. I mean, that's the easiest way to get started. And from there, it builds and builds. And you'll kind of fit, you know, you'll kind of figure out where things fit the best and what give you the most benefit from both the company side and the employee side. And eventually you'll be like us and have lots of programs. So I want to get both of your opinions on the importance of two things. The first is employee development and pipelines to advancement, and the other is employee recognition. Dr. Baildard, I'll start with you. Overall, how crucial are those two elements to creating a psychologically healthy workplace? Well, those are two areas that in general, there's a lot of room for improvement. We do surveys of the U.S. workforce every year to
开始。我的意思是，这是最简单的开始方式。从那里开始，它会不断积累。而且你会，你知道，你会弄清楚事情在哪里最合适，以及什么从公司和员工双方都能给你带来最大的好处。最终你会像我们一样，拥有很多计划。所以我想听听你们俩对两件事重要性的看法。第一是员工发展和晋升渠道，第二是员工认可。巴拉德博士，我先从你开始。总的来说，这两个要素对于创造一个心理健康的工作场所至关重要吗？嗯，这两个领域通常都有很大的改进空间。我们每年对美国劳动力进行调查，以
look at issues that are top of mind and employee attitudes and experiences on the job. And one of the things we find is only about half of U.S. workers say they're satisfied with the growth and development opportunities that they have available to them on the job. Lack of opportunity for advancement and growth in an organization, also year after year is the number two top source of stress that U.S. workers cite. So it's something that's getting in the way of their work performance. So there's lots of opportunity to improve there. Similarly, only 58% of U.S. workers say they feel valued by their employer. And that's a striking figure when I think just over half of U.S. workers say they even feel valued for what they're what they're contributing
查看最受关注的问题以及员工在工作中的态度和经历。我们发现的一件事是，只有大约一半的美国工人表示他们对在工作中可获得的成长和发展机会感到满意。在组织中缺乏晋升和成长的机会，也是年复一年美国工人提到的第二大压力来源。所以这是阻碍他们工作表现的事情。所以那里有很多改进的机会。同样，只有58%的美国工人表示他们感到受到雇主的重视。这是一个惊人的数字，因为我认为只有一半多一点的美国工人表示他们甚至因为他们的贡献而感到受到重视，
on the job. And from our research, we know that feeling valued is linked to higher levels of job satisfaction, higher levels of motivation, and the likelihood that people are actually going to participate in wellness programs and training activities and involvement initiatives. So it's not just isolated to reward and recognition programs. This spills, over into employee performance across the board. So these are big deals for employers. And so we're talking about recognition. Do you think in some cases recognition is more important than pay? Recognition in organizations really consists of both. Monetary and non-monetary forms can be formal or informal. So certainly pay is always an issue. In our surveys we find that's the number one
在工作中。根据我们的研究，我们知道感到受到重视与更高水平的工作满意度、更高水平的动力以及人们实际上会参与健康计划、培训活动和参与倡议的可能性有关。所以它不仅仅局限于奖励和认可计划。这会溢出到全面的员工绩效中。所以这对雇主来说是大事。那么我们正在谈论认可。你认为在某些情况下，认可比薪水更重要吗？组织中的认可实际上包括两者。货币和非货币形式可以是正式的或非正式的。所以薪水当然总是一个问题。在我们的调查中，我们发现这是人们提到的第一大
source of stress is low pay that people cite. But it's one of those issues that when it's insufficient or seen as unfair, it's a huge problem. And all the other perks and award programs and certificates and award ceremonies aren't going to make up for that if people feel like they're unfairly compensated and it's not enough. But once you reach a certain point, it doesn't add value. Once people feel like it's sufficient. So those other things really come into play. And it can be a simple thank you from a colleague or a supervisor for a job well done and feeling like your work was actually appreciated. And there's something in the psychology research that is called effort, reward, imbalance. And so if people feel like what they're putting into their job and their work is out of whack with how they're being recognized and compensated along the way, then that creates additional problems in a workplace.
压力来源是低薪。但这是一个问题，当它不足或被视为不公平时，这是一个巨大的问题。如果人们觉得他们得到的报酬不公平且不够，那么所有的其他津贴、奖励计划、证书和颁奖典礼都无法弥补这一点。但一旦你达到了一定程度，它就不会增加价值。一旦人们觉得它足够了。所以其他事情就真正发挥作用了。它可以是同事或主管对出色工作的一句简单的谢谢，并感到你的工作确实受到赞赏。心理学研究中有一种东西叫做“努力-回报不平衡”。所以如果人们觉得他们投入到工作中的努力与他们在此过程中获得的认可和报酬不匹配，那么这就会在工作场所造成额外的问题。
Yeah, that's very fascinating how it might not necessarily always be so tied. And so with employee development and pipelines, is that something you're seeing more in the workplace today that the companies are coming up with these long range plans for people? People are thinking about it a lot more certainly. You know, the rate of change is increasing. The environment is changing all the time. And so if organizations want to keep up and be competitive in an increasingly global marketplace and more rapid changes, then they have to prepare their workforce to be able to cope with the stress that they face, to be able to handle change and be resilient.
是的，它可能不一定总是联系得那么紧密，这非常迷人。那么对于员工发展和渠道，这是你在今天的工作场所中看到的更多的事情吗，即公司正在为人们制定这些长期计划？人们当然思考得更多了。你知道，变化的速度正在加快。环境一直在变化。所以如果组织想要跟上并在日益全球化的市场和更快速的变化中保持竞争力，那么他们必须准备好他们的劳动力，使其能够应对他们面临的压力，能够处理变化并具有韧性。
So I think a lot of organizations are thinking ahead and understanding that they need to do this, but there's a lot more work to be done. And Mr. Vian, turning over to you, how have those two areas helped your company? That's employee development and pipelines and recognition. Yeah, I think the pipeline is the things that we've done with developing career pipeline and pathways has really helped us separate those that have potential from those who maybe either aren't a best fit for the company or the future of the company and make
所以我认为很多组织都在向前看，并理解他们需要这样做，但还有很多工作要做。维恩先生，转到你这里，这两个领域如何帮助了你们公司？那就是员工发展和渠道以及认可。是的，我认为渠道是我们通过开发职业渠道和路径所做的事情，确实帮助我们区分了那些有潜力的人和那些可能要么不适合公司，要么不适合公司未来的人，并做出
decisions on whether or not we can help people maximize their potential in their career here or beyond or decide that, you know, maybe their career has a better path outside Autosoft. So those are some tough decisions that, you know, some of our managers have to make or help us make. But that's part of the reality of making sure we have the right fit, the right culture, the right people. And as far as the recognition goes, recognition has, I would say out of the surveys we do internally and in all the award programs that we participate in, the recognition is one of the top things that employees respond to and appreciate. They feel valued.
决定我们是否能帮助人们在这里或在其他地方最大化他们的职业潜力，或者决定，你知道，也许他们的职业在Autosoft之外有更好的路径。所以这些是一些艰难的决定，你知道，我们的一些经理必须做出或帮助我们做出。但这是确保我们有正确的匹配、正确的文化、正确的人的现实的一部分。至于认可，认可有，我会说在我们内部进行的调查以及我们参与的所有奖项计划中，认可都是员工回应和赞赏的首要事项之一。他们感到受到重视。
They feel like a part of something big and like their really efforts are well received and appreciated and basically seen by all, including, you know, upper management and myself. And I'd say one of the most difficult things I'm seeing for us as we're evolving and hiring more remote workers is how do you make the remote workers more of a part of the integral part of the culture and the rest of the people? And how do you give them the recognition as a remote employee and make them feel the same as the people that are here? Yeah, that's a great point you make, Mr. Vian, about remote employees. So turning over to Dr. Ballard, how do you engage employees when they're not actually working in? in an office space if they're working remotely. Yeah, this is an important area and one that there's not been a lot of work done.
他们感到自己是大事的一部分，就像他们的努力确实得到了很好的接受和赞赏，并且基本上被所有人看到，包括，你知道，高层管理人员和我自己。而且我会说，随着我们不断演变并雇佣更多的远程员工，我看到的对我们来说最困难的事情之一是，你如何让远程员工更多地成为文化和其余人的组成部分？你如何作为远程员工给予他们认可，并让他们感到与在这里的人一样？是的，维恩先生，你提出的关于远程员工的观点很好。所以转到巴拉德博士，当员工实际上不在办公室工作时，如果他们远程工作，你如何让他们参与进来？是的，这是一个重要的领域，而且在这方面还没有做太多的工作。
And in fact, in most organizations, managers are still working the same way they did in the industrial revolution. Like people are standing in an assembly line cranking out widgets when that's not most of the work that's getting done nowadays. But unfortunately, most managers are never trained in how to manage a remote workforce. And so that's an area where there's a lot more room for development. Now, there is research being done and there is work happening. Unfortunately, it's not translating yet to a majority of workplaces.
事实上，在大多数组织中，经理们仍然以工业革命时期的方式工作。就像人们站在装配线上制造小部件一样，而这并不是当今完成的大部分工作。但不幸的是，大多数经理从未接受过如何管理远程劳动力的培训。所以这是一个还有很大发展空间的领域。现在，正在进行研究，也有工作在进行。不幸的是，它还没有转化为大多数工作场所。
But increasingly, we have access to the technology tools that we need to be able to actually involve and include people who may be working in remote locations, teams who aren't necessarily even in the same physical location at all. We have tools that can facilitate that online through video conferencing and chat functions. And so it's a matter of figuring out how to effectively use those tools. that you don't lose the types of interactions that you have in a face-to-face work environment. So there's a lot of work happening in that area, but it's a huge need for most employers. And to this point, most managers still haven't even been trained in how to do that effectively. And one other question for you, Dr. Ballard. I'm sure many listeners out there have worked someplace that was not psychologically healthy.
但越来越多地，我们拥有所需的工具，能够真正参与和包括可能在远程地点工作的人，那些甚至根本不在同一个物理地点的团队。我们拥有可以通过视频会议和聊天功能在线促进这一点的工具。所以问题在于弄清楚如何有效地使用这些工具。你不会失去你在面对面工作环境中拥有的那种互动。所以在这个领域有很多工作在进行，但对大多数雇主来说，这是一个巨大的需求。到目前为止，大多数经理甚至还没有接受过如何有效地做到这一点的培训。还有一个问题问你，巴拉德博士。我相信很多听众都在不是心理健康的地方工作过。
You talk about how damaging that is from morale and what does that stress do to our mental and physical health? Yeah, we've all probably worked in an environment where we get up in the morning and we dread going in. And no matter what job you're in, everybody has bad days. But there are a lot of environments, unfortunately, where it's just unpleasant to be in. Your day-to-day experience on the job is bad. And stress is a normal part of life. It's a natural reaction that it's designed to help kick us in gear and deal with whatever challenge or threats in front of us. But the reality is that as humans, we are not designed to withstand that day after day after day.
你谈到了这对士气有多大的破坏性，这种压力对我们的身心健康有什么影响？是的，我们可能都曾在这样一个环境中工作过，早上起床时害怕去上班。无论你从事什么工作，每个人都有糟糕的日子。但不幸的是，有很多环境，在那里待着就是不愉快。你在工作中的日常体验很糟糕。压力是生活中的正常部分。这是一种自然的反应，旨在帮助我们进入状态并应对我们面前的任何挑战或威胁。但现实是，作为人类，我们并不是为了日复一日地承受这种压力而设计的。
That's supposed to be ramp up, deal with the threat, and then get back to your baseline and go about your business. So when that chronic stress persists, it puts a lot of wear and tear on your body and your brain. And it can start interfering with your physical health, your mental health. It can interfere with interpersonal relationships. your job performance can suffer. And so if this kind of chronic stress persists from a negative work environment, then it can actually affect people's job performance so that they not only, they don't feel competent on the job, but they're actually not doing their best work.
这本应是一个提升、应对威胁，然后回到基准线并继续处理事务的过程。因此，当这种慢性压力持续存在时，会对你的身体和大脑造成很大的损耗。它开始干扰你的身心健康，干扰人际关系，甚至影响你的工作表现。所以，如果这种来自负面工作环境的慢性压力持续存在，它实际上会影响员工的工作表现，不仅让他们在工作中感到能力不足，而且实际上也无法发挥出最佳水平。
So it's really a shared responsibility between employees and employers to create this environment where people can bring their best to the job. And employers are creating an environment that's conducive to them, being engaged and having a positive work experience. And I imagine the signs of that happening are probably high turnover or low morale productivity, that sort of thing. Yeah, you see on the organizational side, you see higher levels of absenteeism and turnover. You see performance and productivity dropping.
因此，创造一个让员工能够发挥最佳水平的环境，确实是员工和雇主共同的责任。雇主需要创造一个有利于员工投入并获得积极工作体验的环境。我想，这种情况出现的迹象可能是高离职率、士气低落或生产力下降等。是的，在组织层面，你会看到更高水平的缺勤率和离职率，也会看到绩效和生产力的下降。
You may see more conflict or incivility in a workplace. People disengaging and not really giving it they're all. On the business side of things, you might see profitability. sliding, output starting to drop, customer service ratings, dipping, things that all could be signs of something bigger is going on under the surface. Yeah, so you want to, I guess, I'm sure for company, they want to address it before it gets to that point because that's already, you're seeing the effects of people not being happy, not even just happy, but just being miserable on the job.
你可能会在工作场所看到更多的冲突或不文明行为。员工变得消极怠工，没有真正全力以赴。在业务方面，你可能会看到盈利能力下滑、产出开始下降、客户服务评分降低，这些都可能是表面之下存在更大问题的迹象。是的，所以我想，对于公司来说，他们肯定希望在问题发展到那一步之前就解决它，因为那时你已经看到了员工不快乐，甚至不仅仅是不快乐，而是对工作感到痛苦所带来的后果。
Yeah, creating this psychologically healthy environment is an overall approach. And if you strive to do that in a general sense, then, when things are tough. And the recession was a great example of this. If you've already been doing this, then you're better equipped to handle that. And your employees are too. So even organizations that were very psychologically healthy who were doing all the right things, the recession hit. And that was an example of these are forces bigger than the organization. So even good organizations got hit pretty hard and sometimes had to make cuts or layoffs or change things that weren't necessarily positive. But those who had paid attention to creating a psychologically
是的，创造这种心理健康的环境是一个整体的方法。如果你在总体上努力做到这一点，那么当遇到困难时——经济衰退就是一个很好的例子——如果你已经一直在这样做，那么你就能更好地应对。你的员工也是如此。所以，即使是那些心理非常健康、做着所有正确事情的组织，在经济衰退来袭时，也受到了影响。这是一个组织无法控制的外部力量的例子。因此，即使是优秀的组织也受到了沉重打击，有时不得不进行裁员或做出不一定积极的改变。但那些一直致力于创造心理健康环境的组织
healthy environment up to that point handled it better. So it's not only what they're doing, it's how they're going about it. So employees in those circumstances felt like they were in it together. The employer was being open and transparent with them, involving them in problem solving about how they were going to cope with it. And in fact, organizations that were really forward thinking at the time used it as an opportunity to position themselves to be even more successful when the economy turned around. So that's a really concrete example. But you don't want to wait until there's a crisis to start addressing some of these issues because once trust is broken, once there's negativity in the workplace, that's hard to dig out from. And it lasts a long time.
在那个阶段处理得更好。所以，这不仅取决于他们做了什么，还取决于他们是如何做的。在那种情况下，员工感到他们是同舟共济的。雇主对他们保持开放和透明，让他们参与到如何应对困难的决策中。事实上，当时那些真正具有前瞻性的组织利用这个机会，使自己在经济好转时处于更有利的地位。这是一个非常具体的例子。但你不想等到危机出现才开始解决这些问题，因为一旦信任破裂，一旦工作场所出现负面情绪，就很难从中恢复，而且这种影响会持续很长时间。
And it takes a lot of consistency in the future to make up for that. So it's much, much easier to create it to begin with and then use that to help you weather the storms. Yeah. But I guess it's not hopeless if a company or an organization is having that experience where they're like, you know, managers are looking at this, whoa, we've got to make some changes. But it takes a long time to. Yeah, every organization goes through tough times. And there's lots of change happening in organizations. A survey we did a couple years ago, about half the U.S. workforce said they were currently going through major organizational changes or had just gone through them. And that's stressful. Absolutely. So times are going to change. There will be ups and downs, but thinking bigger picture about
未来需要付出大量的持续努力来弥补这一点。因此，从一开始就建立这种环境，然后利用它来帮助你度过难关要容易得多。是的。但我想，如果一家公司或组织正在经历这种情况，比如经理们意识到“哇，我们必须做出一些改变”，这并不是毫无希望的。但这需要很长时间。是的，每个组织都会经历困难时期。组织中发生着很多变化。我们几年前做的一项调查显示，大约一半的美国劳动力表示他们目前正在经历或刚刚经历过重大的组织变革。这很有压力。绝对是这样。所以时代会变，会有起伏，但从大局出发思考
how do we create this healthy environment that's going to support workers, support the business, is going to lead to an environment where everybody can win in the long run. Do you think this is an exciting time to be an employee? I guess it's a funny way to say that? But I guess I just mean, like, is it a time where employees feel empowered about the kind of work they're choosing? And they feel like their employers will create better environments for them? Yeah, I think this is one that it depends a lot on the company. I think in really high performing organizations that under.
如何创造这种支持员工、支持业务的健康环境，将最终带来一个让每个人都能长期获益的环境。你认为现在是作为员工的好时机吗？我想这说法有点奇怪？但我的意思是，现在员工是否对他们选择的工作感到更有自主权？他们是否觉得雇主会为他们创造更好的环境？是的，我认为这在很大程度上取决于公司。我认为在那些真正表现优异的组织中，他们
understand this psychologically healthy workplace concept and are taking those kinds of steps. You know, employees do feel like they have a voice. They do feel like they're involved in decisions that affect them on the job. They have sufficient autonomy and control and flexibility in their life that many people didn't have in the past. And so those are great things, but overall in the U.S. workforce, that's not necessarily the case. You know, in our surveys of U.S. workers, although about two-thirds of working Americans said that their organization is open with them and communicates with them regularly. Only just over half said the organization actually asks them for feedback regularly. And only about four out of ten say the organization
理解这种心理健康工作场所的概念，并正在采取这些措施。你知道，员工确实感到他们有发言权。他们确实感到自己参与了影响他们工作的决策。他们拥有过去许多人所没有的足够的自主权、控制权和生活灵活性。所以这些都是好事，但总体而言，在美国劳动力中，情况并非总是如此。你知道，在我们的美国员工调查中，尽管约三分之二的美国在职人员表示他们的组织对他们开放并定期与他们沟通，但只有略多于一半的人表示组织实际上定期征求他们的反馈。只有大约十分之四的人表示组织
actually listens to their feedback and uses it to make changes. So I think these successful organizations are doing it better and better. But on average in the U.S. workforce, we have a lot of room for growth. And I want to touch on another survey that your office did. So now we're only few months from summer, so that means vacation time. So last year, APA issued a work and well-being survey that found that taking time off helped employees recharge, but those benefits faded after only a few days for most people. How can employers make sure that vacation time is actually beneficial? And also, what tips do you have for employees to make sure that recharging feeling lasts beyond a couple days? Yeah, I'm sure most of us have had the experience where, you know, we take some time off
实际上会倾听他们的反馈并利用它做出改变。所以我认为这些成功的组织做得越来越好。但在美国劳动力平均水平上，我们还有很大的成长空间。我想谈谈你们办公室做的另一项调查。现在离夏天只有几个月了，这意味着假期即将来临。去年，美国心理学会（APA）发布了一项工作与幸福感调查，发现休假有助于员工充电，但对于大多数人来说，这些好处在几天后就消失了。雇主如何确保休假确实有益？此外，你对员工有什么建议，以确保这种充电的感觉能持续几天以上？是的，我相信我们大多数人都经历过，你知道，我们休了一段时间假
and whether it's a staycation or whether you go somewhere, somewhere exciting, you come back to work, and there's the mountain of things waiting for you that have piled up while you were away. And so all that relaxation is out the window the second you go in, and you're actually more stressed than you were before you left because you're behind and everything is due. Deadlines are waiting and it's worse than it was before. And you hear people all the time say, you know, this is what I get for taking time off. Yeah, of course. And so unfortunately, we know from the research that when that happens, when there's a backlog and people come back to that kind of heavier demand, the bigger that is, the faster those benefits of taking
无论是居家度假还是去某个令人兴奋的地方，当你回到工作岗位时，有一堆事情等着你，这些事情在你离开时堆积如山。所以，当你走进办公室的那一刻，所有的放松都烟消云散了，你实际上比离开前压力更大，因为你落后了，一切都到了截止日期。最后期限在等着你，情况比以前更糟。你经常听到人们说：“这就是我休假换来的结果。”是的，当然。不幸的是，我们从研究中得知，当这种情况发生时，当有积压工作，人们回到那种更繁重的需求中时，积压越多，休假带来的好处消失得就越快。
time off fade away. So, yeah, there's some things that employees and employers can do. And again, this is one of those shared responsibility issues to try to make those last longer. I mean, it's in the best interest of employees and the company to try to make the most gains from people having time off. So on the employee side of things, when they're off, they need to make sure they're getting the adequate stress recovery experiences.
所以，是的，员工和雇主可以做一些事情。同样，这也是一个共同责任的问题，以试图让这些好处持续更长时间。我的意思是，让人们从休假中获得最大收益符合员工和公司的最佳利益。因此，在员工方面，当他们休假时，他们需要确保获得足够的压力恢复体验。
And from psychology research, we know to recover from stress and prevent burnout, you need to have time when you're not working, when you're not thinking about work, even if you're not at work, but you're getting pinged with messages and you're constantly ruminating about your deadlines coming up when you get back, that prevents you from actually recovering from stress. You need to engage actively in some relaxation activities, whatever that is for you. It may be laying on a beach. It may be reading a book. It may be doing yoga or meditation. Whatever it is that relaxes you, you need to engage in that. You also need to stay connected and involved in some other interesting, challenging activities that aren't work related, something that stimulates you
从心理学研究中我们知道，要从压力中恢复并防止倦怠，你需要有不工作、不思考工作的时间。即使你不在工作，但如果你不断收到消息，不断反思回来后即将到来的截止日期，这会阻止你真正从压力中恢复。你需要积极参与一些放松活动，无论那对你来说是什么。可能是躺在沙滩上，可能是读书，可能是做瑜伽或冥想。无论什么让你放松，你都需要参与其中。你还需要保持联系并参与一些其他有趣的、具有挑战性的非工作相关活动，一些能刺激你的事情
beyond just work. And then finally, you need to get enough good quality sleep. And that's an issue. Sometimes you pack so much into a vacation that you're exhausted when you come back. And you say, I need a vacation for my vacation, right? So those are things that during the vacation experience, employees need to do in order to recharge and come back at their best. Now, the shared responsibility piece, and this requires some planning ahead and some work when you get back to the office. And employees need to do this with their teams and with their employers. One is actually plan ahead. So when you know you're going to be out, have a conversation.
不仅仅是工作。最后，你需要获得足够的高质量睡眠。这是一个问题。有时你在假期里塞满了太多事情，以至于回来时精疲力竭。你会说：“我需要为我的假期再休个假”，对吧？所以这些是员工在度假期间需要做的事情，以便充电并以最佳状态回来。现在，关于共同责任的部分，这需要提前计划，并在回到办公室后做一些工作。员工需要与他们的团队和雇主一起做这件事。第一是真正提前计划。所以当你确定要休假时，进行一次沟通。
Who's going to handle the things you normally do while you're out of the office? Share your expectations about your availability while you're off. Are you going to check email? If an emergency comes up, should people contact you? That way there's not a misunderstanding with people feeling like they don't want to bother you or knowing that you are going to check it and not feeling like you're on call 24-7 while you're taking that time off. That also helps encouraging teams to schedule vacations in advance so that so that too many people aren't out right when a big deadline is looming.
当你不在办公室时，谁来处理你通常做的事情？分享你对休假期间可用性的期望。你会查看电子邮件吗？如果出现紧急情况，人们应该联系你吗？这样就不会产生误解，人们不会觉得他们不想打扰你，或者知道你会查看邮件，而不会觉得你在休假期间必须24小时待命。这也有助于鼓励团队提前安排假期，这样就不会有太多人在大限将至时休假。
And that coordination across the work unit is important. Organizations need to develop supervisors as well so that they're tracking employees' vacation time and use of that. They're encouraging and supporting employees in taking that time off so that employees feel like they can actually take time off and it won't be viewed negatively. And then training supervisors to better understand work stress so that they can identify it if they're seeing it in their employees. and direct them toward resources or strategies to help manage that stress effectively.
这种跨工作单元的协调很重要。组织还需要培养主管，让他们跟踪员工的休假时间和使用情况。他们要鼓励和支持员工休假，让员工觉得他们确实可以休假，而且不会被负面看待。然后培训主管更好地理解工作压力，以便他们在员工身上看到压力时能够识别出来，并引导他们利用资源或策略来有效地管理压力。
Cross-training workers on your team is another great one. So if you have somebody out, there's somebody else who actually has the skill set to be able to pick up that work temporarily while the other person's out. On the back end of vacations, easing back in is really important. And I mentioned coming back to that mountain, if you can ease yourself back into work, so maybe the first day that someone is back, they're, doing, they're working remotely or telecommuting or maybe they're, they're blocking out time on their schedule to catch up on the hundreds of emails that are piled up. So they don't walk in the door and have 10 people at their office waiting for them and the expectation that they do it
对团队成员进行交叉培训是另一个好方法。所以如果有人休假，有其他人具备相应的技能，能够在对方休假期间暂时接手工作。在假期结束时，平稳过渡非常重要。我提到了回到那座“大山”的问题，如果你能让自己平稳地回到工作中，比如某人回来的第一天，他们进行远程办公，或者他们在日程表中预留时间来处理堆积的数百封电子邮件。这样他们就不会一进门就有10个人在办公室等着他们，并期望他们立即完成所有事情。
all immediately. So try to ease it back in and dig out rather than getting overwhelmed immediately. And then I think the final, the big picture issue is looking at the culture in an organization. So in most companies, you're not going to have somebody actually saying, well, you shouldn't take time off and I'm going to penalize you or look badly on you if you're actually using your vacation time. That doesn't usually happen. But what does happen a lot of times is, you know, what's being communicated indirectly in an organization? Are you holding up as an example of the perfect employee, the worker who never takes time off or who responds to emails at midnight on Saturday? And if you're saying this is the gold star employee, then indirectly you're communicating to your workforce that it's bad to take time off and that you should be on call 24-7. So even if those are not explicit expectations that are laid out, look at how things are being modeled by leaders, look at what's being reinforced.
所以尽量平稳过渡并逐步处理，而不是立即感到不知所措。我认为最后一个大局问题是审视组织的文化。在大多数公司，你不会听到有人直接说：“你不应该休假，如果你真的休假，我会惩罚你或对你有看法。”这种情况通常不会发生。但经常发生的是，你知道，组织中在间接传达什么？你是否将从不休假或在周六午夜回复电子邮件的员工树立为完美员工的榜样？如果你说这是金牌员工，那么你就在间接向员工传达休假是不好的，你应该24小时待命。所以即使这些不是明确的期望，也要看看领导者是如何示范的，看看什么得到了强化。
And if it's reinforcing things that are negative or not what you intend, clarify those expectations and adjust that. So I think those bigger cultural issues are really important too. So one final question. Where can people go to learn about the psychologically healthy workplace awards and also about the Office of Applied Psychology? People can go online to APA.org slash applied dash psychology. And there's information about the psychologically healthy workplace awards available there. Wonderful. Well, thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Ballard and Mr. Vian. It's been a really fascinating conversation. Thank you. Thank you. If you've been a longtime listener or are new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. And if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, we'd like to hear from you directly, so if you have
如果它强化的是负面的或非你所愿的东西，请澄清这些期望并进行调整。所以我认为这些更大的文化问题也非常重要。最后一个问题。人们可以去哪里了解心理健康工作场所奖以及应用心理学办公室？人们可以上网访问 APA.org/applied-psychology。那里有关于心理健康工作场所奖的信息。太棒了。好吧，非常感谢你们的加入，Ballard博士和Vian先生。这是一次非常引人入胜的谈话。谢谢。谢谢。如果你是我们的老听众或者是新听众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。如果你有时间，写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。此外，我们想直接听取你的意见，所以如果你有
any questions, comments, or ideas to share, you can email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A at APA.com. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes the podcast APA Journal's Dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit speaking of psychology.org to listen to more episodes and to see resources on the topics we discuss. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
任何问题、评论或想法要分享，你可以发电子邮件给我，地址是 K-Luna@APA.org。那是 K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。Speaking of Psychology 是 APA 播客网络的一部分，其中包括关于新心理学研究的播客“APA Journals Dialogue”和关于心理学实践的“Progress Notes”。你可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集并查看我们讨论主题的资源。我是美国心理学会的 Caitlin Luna。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。